johnny depp's defamation case against
his ex-wife amber heard may be over but
now new shocking claims and accusations
are coming to light we had a
conversation pertaining to the surprise
she left in the boss's bed
prior to leaving the apartment and when
you refer to the surprise in the boss's
bed what are you referring to
the defecation
as if hearing that during the six-week
trial wasn't surprising enough there's
now more to stomach in more than 6 000
pages of pre-trial documents that were
unsealed over the weekend yeah there's a
lot to go through claims from both sides
that they tried to submit as evidence
but ultimately didn't get approved
including the claim that johnny wanted
to introduce nude photos of amber into
evidence the actress's lawyers clapped
back and called the move inappropriate
and irrelevant they doubled down by
saying amber's nude images as well as
her past as an exotic dancer happened
years before she met the pirates star
they also claimed that johnny was
attempting to frivolously and
maliciously suggest or imply that amber
was at one time an escort and when it
comes to amber's side her team also
dropped some bombs
on your left side
the docs reveal amber's team tried
suggesting johnny was taking erectile
dysfunction medication specifically
submitting into evidence prescriptions
for nexium cialis and valtrex implying
it may be the motivation behind his
alleged abuse bajani's lawyers called bs
and said it was just a tactic for amber
to embarrass him in court of course in
the end the verdict fell into johnny's
favor with the jury deciding amber did
in fact defame him we are grateful so
grateful to the jury for their careful
deliberation
to the judge and the court staff who
have devoted an enormous amount of time
and resources towards this case
and now amber is planning to fight back
her next move is appeal there was no
heartbroken she is heartbroken and one
of the first things that she said when
she came back from the verdict when we
went into the conference room was i am
so sorry to all these women
that said that yes she felt like she had
let down all of these women because she
had more evidence than most people do
and yet they still didn't believe her
but johnny has countered her appeal do
you have to plan a strategy to
to respond to that absolutely and we did
that's his attorney camille vasquez
talking to cbs morning's gail king last
week where she revealed johnny's legal
strategy in response to amber's appeal
mr depp ended up filing his own appeals
so that the court could have the full
record and you know she insists on
continuing to litigate this matter
we have to protect our clients interests
we just are hopeful that the court will
uphold the verdict which we think was
the right verdict and allow both parties
to to move on
[Music]
you